Here's a new imaging technology. I just heard about the breast cancer summit sounds fantastic
I haven't had time to research it yet and it's useful as a detecting metabolic activity or if it's
just a screening tool, that's much safer than a mammogram. But here's the website so others can get
started other old research and if desired. If you've heard them, please share what you've discovered.
Well, what it is, I should have done a screenshot of the website so you can see it, but everybody can
go to the website. It's a new ultrasound machine where you lay out a table at your breast
kind of sags into this space so you get really a better three-dimensional picture of what's
going on in your breast. So it wouldn't be, it's not a tool to detect metabolic activity like a
PET scan, but it's a safe, less invasive than a mammogram or a CT scan or a PET scan
or an MRI even and it gives you just a really nice three-dimensional picture of a mass.
So if there is a lesion, a mass of any kind, you could get a better
picture of a measurement of it so you know if it's growing or not growing,
that's really the benefit of this tool. Now it's going to be years before it's really widely
available. That's just the way things move because the sun shirts, you know, a couple hundred thousand
dollar piece of equipment that hospitals are going to have to add. If they don't see the financial
benefit from it, it's going to be slow to add these things. But it's a great tool,
it's neat that there is some innovation because there hasn't been a whole lot of innovation in the
energy for a very long time.